his name is saffin
and what does he want revenge
what i really wanted from stefan was to
make him unsettling
thinking of himself as being heroic
i'm a man willing to kill the person you
love most
i've already lost everyone i've ever
loved
what he wants and what he's willing to
do
makes him a very frightening character
both personally to bond but also on a
global level
we both eradicate people to make the
world a better place
i just want to be a little tidier
saffin is a formidable adversary
james bond has to adapt to that what is
it
you don't know what this is he's going
to kill millions
if we don't do this there will be
nothing left to save
i've made you redundant no
not as long as there are people like you
in the world
you